riesgo 4 es de esos juegos que son tan
buenos que a día de hoy cuentan con 300
millones de versiones y ha salido para
casi cualquier consola que te puedas
imaginar y es que quieren no amarres de
nivel 4 con su mezcla perfecta de acción
y terror su protagonista con cabello de
ángel y pectorales de acero y sobre todo
su enorme cantidad de secretos que se
descubrían año tras año y es que uno
pensaría que ya con más de diez años
encima y con la gran cantidad de
versiones que el juego ya tiene ya no
hay nada más por descubrir pero qué
equivocado que estarás cabrón pues
reciben ebook 4 aún tiene un par de
ministerios que la mayoría de personas
aunque han jugado mil veces no conocen y
es por eso que te voy a mostrar cuatro
de los misterios más grandes de resident
evil 4
[Música]
a
cuando lea sabroso kennedy llega a la
prisión una de las primeras cosas que
podemos ver y una de las más
perturbadoras es esta caja pues cuando
nos acerquemos y la abramos una bolsa
blanca comenzará a moverse como loca y
no se detendrá a menos que disparemos
porque luego puede estar muy sabroso y
todo lo que quieras pero que no se nos
olvide que es americano así que por
supuesto que lo primero que hace el ver
algo que desconoce es agarrarlo a tiros
y descargar de la pistola entera por
curiosidad el punto es que claramente lo
que sea que esté en esta bolsa parece
estar vivo y mueres y lyon lo ataca a
pesar de que muchas personas han tratado
de ver lo que es nadie ha logrado nada
teorías hay muchas desde las que dicen
que hay una nueva especie de plagas ahí
hasta la más creíble que dice que en esa
bolsa hay partes desmembradas de algunos
regeneradores que se desecharon y se
mueven al tratar de reconstruirse pero
no hay nada confirmado incluso la misma
capcom cuando un fan le preguntó acerca
de esto dio a entender que jamás dirán
lo que está en esa bolsa pues prefieren
que algunas cosas en el juego se
mantengan como un secreto
[Música]
y
para los amantes de resident ebook 4 un
viejo conocido hace un par de años todo
el mundo se sorprendió de que alguien
puede encontrar un personaje secreto que
nadie había visto antes pues fuera de
los límites del juego encontraron a esta
persona bonachón a salvándonos desde lo
lejos y aunque aún no se sabe con
seguridad quién es sí que es una
sorpresa saber que aún a una década del
estreno del juego aún tenía un par de
secretos por encontrar
a
una regla de oro en los videojuegos es
que no puede haber niños
o sea si los puede ver pero se tiene
como costumbre evitar mostrar a niños en
videojuegos violentos y menos en un
juego como radiactivo 4 en donde el lyon
con su poderosísimo cabello rubio
masacra media españa
en conclusión en los videojuegos no se
demostrarán niños en situaciones
violentas es como una regla ética que
todos tienen es por eso que en base a 4
no vemos ni a un solo niño pero para dar
una explicación a todo esto capcom
decido incluir un secreto que explicaría
todo pues que no terminamos el juego
luego en la secuencia de créditos a
través de imágenes nos cuenta la
historia de la aldea y de los niños
antes de que llegara a formar y los
volvieran locos a todos básicamente
durante los créditos se nos cuenta cómo
salir su pandilla al llegar al pueblo
comenzaron a infectar a las personas con
las plagas incluyendo a los niños pero
al ser más pequeños sus cuerpos no
soportaron el parásito y todos murieron
no es que nunca hubieran niños en el
pueblo claro que los hubo pero entonces
sadler los mató a todos
[Música]
esto no es un misterio como tal pero yo
que jugué el juego hace muchos años
nunca lo había visto y me pareció muy
interesante como para no incluirlo y es
que en cierta parte del juego estar
escondía en una habitación oculta una
pintura muy antigua en la pared que nos
enseña a un grupo de personas de una
antigua cultura haciendo sacrificios y
metiendo las plagas en otras personas
esta pintura está aquí para mostrar los
que no todo es hombre lado sadler los
humanos siempre hemos sido unos cabrones
sanguinarios y desde hace muchos años
antes de los eventos del juego las
plagas han estado muy presentes en estas
tierras
residente 4 tiene una infinidad de mods
o trucos o llámalo como quieras es decir
puedes hacer prácticamente lo que
quieras
tengo de tu propia mente
uno de los trucos más usados son los
wolfpack o el núcleo que son comandos
que te permiten atravesar los límites
del juego para atravesar paredes o
incluso el suelo muchas personas lo han
usado para explorar y curiosamente han
encontrado fuera de los límites del
juego mucha munición plantas armas y
demás cosas pero hay un objeto que aún
no se ha podido obtener y es esta carta
explorando por la zona inicial del
pueblo se encontró esta carta debajo del
suelo que a pesar de que brilla como
cualquier otro objeto con el que puedes
interactuar en el juego no podrás
obtener esta carta ni al que pases a
través de ella esto es debido a que en
ocasiones y sobre todo en resident ebook
4 cuando un objeto está fuera de los
límites del juego ya que no se supone
que nadie lo vea los desarrolladores no
se molestan en agregar una funcionalidad
correcta por lo que puede que encuentres
el objeto aquí pero comando interacción
puede estar en cualquier otro lugar del
mapa en el suelo debajo del suelo o
incluso en algún lugar del cielo es
complicado y es por eso que nadie aún
sabe qué es lo que contiene esta carta a
cómo lo veo hay dos posibilidades la
primera es que esta carta sea un simple
objeto usa durante una etapa temprana de
desarrollo que fue desechada más
adelante contienen nada en especial y
aunque es lo más probable no nos
olvidemos que estamos hablando de ruedas
y del ebook 4 un juego en donde aún
después de 12 años siguieron encontrando
secretos así que tal vez esa carta tenga
escrito algo oculto que probablemente
nunca podamos ver
[Música]
es un hecho que es de nivel 4 es un
juego sorprendente a pesar de que ya
tiene sus años y las personas lo juegan
una y otra vez aún hay cosas que muchas
personas desconocen y aunque te acabo de
contar cuatro de los secretos menos
conocidos del juego quién sabe es
probable que el juego no esconda un par
de secretos que tal vez nunca podamos
saber no quiero dormir quiero respuestas
definitivamente necesitan cuatro es un
juego que nunca deja de asombrarnos y
probablemente nunca deje de hacerlo no
sólo porque es un juego increíble pero
porque últimamente los rumores sobre un
remake han estado más fuertes que nunca
y es que imagínense si se encontraron
cientos de secretos en el juego original
cómo será con el remake bueno habrá que
seguir esperando hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]